[Music]
step one of having a successful hunt is
planning and breakfast we have a map of
squint this is how you spell it
I've pronounced it SEC wium sequin
sequence sequitur M SEC one sacrum so
wet and swim we find squash should we
get breakfast first
so most importantly we need to figure
out where we're gonna go so if we come
up right here on swim young this way
we're gonna make a left on Woodcock and
Woodcock intersects with kitchen dick
okay I mean if we have no luck here we
can always come back home we could
probably just swim across the ocean
I forgot my swimsuit you guys ready
ready I just need to get out of swim and
then up to this way
sounds good there you go permanent so
what we have to do is just use band-aids
we had no other option and I have one
single band-aid
I'm not even going that far reading move
[Music]
continue on u.s. 101 West for four miles
and then we then we turn right on
kitchen oh my gosh we have a future may
be short-lived but we have one I think
we're gonna have a really good luck here
pretty but what the hell
one single tree three trees like if
swatches out or we're gonna find so
easily because it's there's nothing for
him to hide behind maybe that's what we
need to do she doing I'm ready for my
picture Bigfoot can swim or has a boat I
don't think he's here
we need to reassess the map so
apparently this right here does not mean
trees I think it's a house
no Tracy there's a boat we're not
getting on a boat
squash he can't swim there's no swimming
and swim rhymin and swim anymore yeah we
are
Oh No look look so you find the trigger
here what's this Olympic Discovery Trail
oh let's go we need to go to the forest
great you know what this map means no I
failed that part of my SATs
I was below average did not realize like
you don't need to read maps no that's
like stupid
and squid and me and swim trees oh look
at this I think we're getting somewhere
you're left to the left to the left no
we're now entering the wildlife reserve
and I have a feeling that I have a good
feeling that I have a feeling that I'm
gonna feel something I don't feel
anything yet
[Music]